[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are gonna be talking about building a
school for Humanity we have the great
vision Lakhani joining us well thank you
for having me
really appreciate coming on to the show
so five years now as the founder and CEO
of mine valley while i've been founded
CEO for almost ten years but five years
since we became a company focused on
transformational education yes and
transformational education is very broad
we have a long list of items that can
maximize both the individuals potential
of education as well as kind of a
collective maximizing all of my human
collective potential so now you're you
know for the last five years that you've
been building out the the actual
university of going to different places
over the summers the actual quests that
have been built there's a lot of
different components to this so let's
have you start off by teaching us about
the components and let's hear about it
so so I started out actually not far
from here on Market Street in Harrison
and this was San Francisco in 2002 2001
2002 the.com bubble had just burst I
remember
April 2001 14,000 people lost their job
so I was living here in the city
unemployed completely broke I remember
attending pink slip parties and sending
out my resume to every company on
Craigslist that would hire me and
eventually I got a job but it wasn't a
great job so I remember I got on Google
Google was maybe a very early search
engine back then and I was just seeking
help I was I can't remember what I typed
in maybe it was something like why does
life suck so bad and I discovered a
class on meditation so I took the class
and something incredible happened within
one week so I was working in sales
technology sales within one week of
taking that class my sales doubled and
this dis baffled me because you know
maybe I had hit a lucky streak I thought
okay it's gonna go back down to its
usual average again
stayed there and then but in a few weeks
it doubled again and within a few months
it doubled again in a span of four
months I got promoted three times
because I was tapping into these parts
of myself that I hadn't learned in
formal education and I was I was baffled
at how fast I was accelerating because
rather than start my day the usual way I
was now starting my David meditation I
would apply quite a visualization and
goal-setting to sales I would apply all
of these techniques I was learning as I
was on the phone and I was crushing it
in four months I got promoted three
times in at the age of 26 I was made
director of sales for the company
shipped over the New York to run their
office now I stay with that company for
around 18 months and then I thought I
need to do something on my own and I
remember Nelson Mandela said if you want
to change the world change education so
I thought I gotta go an education
because if I want to create a big impact
education is where it's at and when I
asked myself what was the best education
I got it wasn't my computer engineering
degree at the University of Michigan it
was a two-day class I took on meditation
so I quit and I became a meditation
instructor and by the way I was married
at that time and if you want to really
piss off your wife quit your high-paying
job and become a meditation instructor
it's the fastest way to see everything
in your bank account start dropping and
dropping and dropping but that's that's
how I stopped it right I said it it was
low pay but I was fulfilled teaching
people now from that what year was a
this was 2003 2000 2004 then I started
building websites and meditation we need
a pause because yeah this is really
important back story I'm really happy
that you're taking us through this back
story so the one aspect of it that I
think we really need to highlight is
what about meditation amplified your
sales so much okay so I'm gonna ask you
for permission to not judge me with what
I'm going to say absolutely and I know
that simulation series focuses you bring
in a lot of incredible scientific minds
right and I know Nicole Bradford right
who's one of the leading scientific
minds here when it comes to everything
from air are to be are to neuro
neuroscience was just on the show and I
actually was hanging out with Nicole and
we had the same conversation and I have
to tell her I know you're a scientist
but just be open to what I'm about to
say what happened when I took that
meditation class is I learned to tap
into intuition now a lot of people when
they say intuition they go [ __ ] and
because it brings to mind these like
these horn artists psychics that you see
in the streets of New York I'm not
talking about that I'm talking about
being able to get still and listen to
this inner voice within and access
information that we do not access with
our with our ordinary Minds so at this
class I learned a technique to access
altered states of mind particularly
alpha and theta states while accessing
these alpha and theta states while being
fully conscious usually if you go into a
theta level you drift off you fall
asleep theta as the dream state but what
if you can access that dream state while
being fully conscious
now here's what was happening we would
have to go to the San Francisco Public
Library check out the yellow pages of
the territory we were assigned and then
call every lawyer in that territory so
let's say you had San Antonio you
started a you go on to Z calling every
lawyer and these lawyers would pick up
the phone you go um mr. Phil III I'm
from X and X company I have the software
do you happen to have a problem with
with you know a B and C and a lawyer
basically say [ __ ] off kid I'm busy
don't you ever call me again right so
it's a very distressing job because you
get told to [ __ ] off more times then
then you could possibly imagine
now I had a different approach I would
meditate I would use the Yellow Pages
now this was in the days of the Yellow
Pages right but then I would get myself
into this calm state so even if I was
told to [ __ ] off I would be Zen about it
but here's the next step I would move my
hand close my eyes move my hand across
the yellow pages and get an impulse on
who to call and I'd intuitively choose
the attorneys and sometimes I would say
okay don't waste your time with this guy
call this guy and in one it overnight my
sales doubled just from going from a
completely random approach to looking at
a name and
checking with my gut if I should make
this call sales doubled and it stayed at
that level right now the thing about
sales is it's it's data-driven I know
because you're tracking your login your
sales every day for months I know the
number of calls I need to get to the
next level and and the number of calls I
need to to create X amount of Commission
that doubled and that was what blew my
mind and that was what made me go deeper
into this to understand all of these
different aspects of transformation
because I wanted to see how far could I
go could I use this to heal myself could
I use this to visualize my goals could I
use this to bend reality yes and that's
what blue blew me away that's why I
decided to dedicate my life to taking
this and making it more commonplace yes
yes there was so little that we actually
understand about altered states of mind
and about the true power of unlocking
the full human potential so I'm glad
that I started that process young and
then so then you figured out okay well I
may as well quit this really high-paying
job and I want to start a meditation
become a meditation teacher and then so
now you're trying to bring the this
intuition like power as well as this
difference yeah so work so for the
earliest of MindValley
I was teaching meditation in New York in
London I started the the second most
popular social bookmarking service after
delicious it was way back in 2005 I
started them early because I was a
software engineer right so I was a I was
coding that was what I did during the
daytime and I was teaching meditations
on nights and weekends what I found is
that you know sometimes I think life
pushes you where you need to be every
one of my software projects even though
there were incredible ideas I came up
with an early version of Instagram as
early as 2005 but the timing was off all
of my software ideas died they didn't
get funded they you know they they kind
of self imploded but every time I did
something in the transformation space I
would get lucky but then I would tell
myself no no one's gonna take me
seriously my friends who what doctors
and lawyers have been a laugh at me no
one's gonna believe this [ __ ] I'm gonna
put it aside it'll just be my personal
part and then I go on to my next
software project which would ultimately
fail and eventually I I
picked up that maybe maybe the universe
was trying to push me into going into
transformational education and when I
decided to commit myself to that
that's when mine Valley exploded and so
that's what we do right now our goal and
we've been doing this since November
2013 when we launched mine Valley
Academy our goal is to take
transformational education and make it
so popular so cool so epic that this is
what people want that this is more
important than the Ivy League degrees
that this is what employees want
employers want to see in their employees
and when I say transformation now it's
not just meditation and intuition it's
biohacking it's it's being able to
access flow States it's it's been green
kills programs on longevity it's it's
all of these different things that we
are bringing together under the
MindValley umbrella from Jim quick
teaching speed learning to lisa nichols
teaching communication and public
speaking to alan watts teaching is Alan
Watts the Sun teachings and philosophy
our goal is to take all of these
transformational ideas and make them so
epically cool that people make them a
part of their daily lives and that sort
of transformational dissemination of
information and inspiration right for
people across the world at a scale of
being able to take these quests it's a
quest it's a simple as signing up for
one quest right or for becoming a
student and doing three of these quests
a year and these quests are epic and
they're transformative for people's
lives and you want to get them into the
hands of employers and you actually just
came from a meeting in the South Bay
with the right lawyer realm to scale
this to more yeah and so what what
you're talking about is this is quest so
on one hand we bring in great teachers
on the other hand because of my
background in software engineering we
developed so I think like an engineer so
we developed a platform called mine
Valley quests which blows away online
courses for example the average online
course has an eight percent completion
rate right most people over 90% of
people who buy programs on on these
online education sites do not complete
them with quests we're able to drive
completion rates as much as 50 to 60
sometimes 80% right we're looking at 10
xing that so quest is a different type
of learning from a traditional online
course if it's gamified it's more fun
it's more exciting and so we put dosti
together and our goal is to create a
global school that can transform a
billion people mm-hmm
I like the ambition of the scale of
doubling the doubling scale by a price
scale the impacting a billion people the
singularity University explorations
right yes I'm a big follower of
singularity University and XPrize I used
to be on the board of the innovation
board for the XPrize Foundation and
that's what pushes me to think like this
and so the the quest side of things is
people signing up anywhere from three
hundred to a thousand bucks for this
quest and quest go from a month to a
couple months well what we found is that
the magic number is a 30 day
transformation and what makes quests
unique is micro slice learning you don't
go and watch a 5 hour video rather you
watch a 10 to 20-minute video every day
for 30 days and the videos are designed
to stack on behaviors right because you
can watch a one-hour lesson and you're
gonna get knowledge but to get
transformation you got to learn and
apply learn and apply and repeat for a
certain amount of time because that's
what creates that transformation so
quest are designed to accelerate
transformation and and so we can do some
pretty epic things with the teachers
we've brought in we can teach people to
access intuition we can teach people to
to radically transform their help by
changing their eating habits way more
effective than dieting which is a whole
other story dieting is [ __ ] we can
teach people how to accelerate muscle
growth using optimized super slow
strength training we can teach people to
extend their lifespan with longevity
training from Ben Greenfield we can
teach people to double their reading
speed with with meta learning training
from Jim quake so each quest in 30 days
up levels you as a human being this is
the closest I believe the school the
world has to Professor Xavier's school
for training x-men
mmm-hmm yeah and I like the thirty-day
about 20 minute video and then you have
some sort of applied learning and that
stacks every single day for 30 days yeah
like that school for superheroes right
okay so and all across right now these
different transformations for different
potentials that we can unlock about
ourselves
then there's the quests and then there's
the the campus that moves year to year
right yes it was in Barcelona last year
Tallinn Estonia this like this summer
which just happened and you went from
300 students to a thousand students and
so what you're talking about so sequest
we have 200,000 lifelike students going
through quests right currently yeah but
if you're talking about a campus what we
wanted to do is we realized that if you
really want to transform people so there
are five things that cause
transformation five things that cause
you to to shift and expand your mind and
your thinking as a human being and you
know some of these things are fairly
obvious journaling critical reflection
or practicing going out and actually
doing the work but one of the things
that causes transformation is community
we transform when we're around other
transformed individuals I'm sure I'm
sure you've heard that that idea that
you are the some of the five people
closest to you for example if your
friends are obese you're more likely to
be obese
if your friends are fit you're more
likely to be fit so what we found is
that they're inspirational if it was the
future you're gonna be you're gonna stop
to think like that right so what we
found my friends are all whacked out on
don't I just want to say that and that
that's a that's a perfect counter to
that is if we're hanging out people
there's not as inspired right yeah you
you don't end up being in spite so what
you want to do is what we found many of
us students want it to come together so
we started creating these events around
the world and so mine got the University
if you want to join Harvard University
you can take a single Harvard class you
can become a member of Harvard online
and take multiple classes or you can
join you apply
you join Harvard University and you take
classes in you're on a campus it's the
same way with mine Valley you can take a
single mine Valley quest you can become
a mine Valley student online that's free
quest a year and you know we have people
guiding you you there's a there's an
online assessment so we figure out where
what you need to what aspect of your
being you need to invest in but you can
apply and become a mine Valley full
student and what this means is you now
don't just study online but you get to
attend a global campuses and our
campuses range from a 30 day campus that
moves to a different city every July
thousands of people come to the city it
just happened in Tallinn Estonia two
campuses like a fest which is a festival
and that's happening in November
hundreds of entrepreneurs will move to
Valley for around six seven days in
November to go through you know this
week of transformation so we are a
massive distributed University we don't
own any buildings everything our
campuses rotate everything is in the
clouds and now what we're doing with
that is no weeping we've been bringing
this to consumers for several years now
we launched a quest model around 20 20
months ago and now we're expanding the
companies and we're expanding the school
so we're about to bring this to schools
in Finland because we believe that
teenagers also deserve this type of
transformation and now what we are most
excited by is we're bringing this to
companies in Silicon Valley because one
of our big passions is we want to take
work and make work so much more
magnificent than it is if you look at
the statistics 54% of Americans
according to Gallup dislike their jobs
and when you go to work you're getting
paid but work is also extracting
something from you it's extracting
longevity it's extracting help it's
causing people to get stressed out it's
causing worse a worsening of your
personal relationships to many people
especially here in the Bay Area work way
too hard
and so it's a third of our lives work
way too hot don't sleep well their
cognitive functioning is going down look
look at what happened recently with Elon
Musk right and so there's this breakdown
that's happening and what we're doing is
we're turning companies into oases and
so
Panisse that plug into mine dolly within
a few years their employees will
actually get healthier while working for
these companies they and us as these
employees get healthier they're more
productive they love their job small
employee retention going and goes up a
profit per employee goes up because we
are taking employees and turning and
magnifying their skills and making them
healthier making a healthier more
productive happier more contributing
members of their team for just 20
minutes a day of their time 10 to 20
minutes a day yeah and it's not even
like around the clock
typically a company would put their
employees through three Qwest a year
yeah so that's three months a year 20
minutes a day but the elements it seems
like a no-brainer right companies and
again these courses the quests are
taught by a lot of global leaders which
is exactly so what you need and they're
like you said it's in the cloud scalable
something great about your campuses you
said we don't know in any buildings
right you guys all just go to Raleigh or
go to Talon or these different places in
the world once in July once and for this
a fest that you're having in Bali this
year something interesting that you were
teaching me about was that you have not
only these young people like you're
going to teach at in young schools like
in Finland right now but you have people
that are 30 40 50 60 coming to your
campuses that are bringing their kids
right and so this turns into a community
that is gathering the kids are
interacting with the kids the parents
with the kids it's big community that
time yes yes so part about education as
you bring your kids along and the reason
for that is because I believe that the
way we raise our kids has has gotten
dysfunctional since the industrial city
in dust really revolutionizing small
villages in the 19th century kids would
spend more time with adults right and
the entire village would raise the kids
the kids were not just with their
parents and then a school they were
interacting with the entire village
learning from different people and then
the Industrial Revolution comes in as
soon as Calvin Coolidge said in 1920s
the point of education is to create
wheels and the cogs of cogs in the
wheels of
and so it certainly became about
efficient efficiency we take the kids
away from the parents we put the kids in
school so the kids aren't bothering the
parents the kids come back from school
they do their homework they go to bed
and when is the last time you took your
kid to the office so they could
understand what you do right I remember
speaking to Naveen Jane who I believe is
an incredible guy
billionaire started that incredible
company by him I know he's gonna be a
guest on your show and I asked Naveen
because he's got incredibly successful
kids I asked Naveen what makes your
children successful and he says look
from the time my son uncle was 6 years
old I would take him to these networking
meetings he would interact with my
friends he would be there just as a
six-year-old walking around talking to
all of these incredible entrepreneurs
and not surprisingly Naveen ended up
graduating from Harvard starting some
incredible nonprofits and companies and
because his mind was exposed to all - to
a whole new way of thinking rather than
what school tells you you need to be so
with MindValley we want to give that
gift to the children of all our students
so when you go to mine Valley University
you bring your kids and your kids will
have classes by themselves we have
classes for kids from 6 to 12 we have
classes for teenagers and then we have
classes for Alice and we have classes
where everyone comes together and we and
you know you do with people are doing
this for 30 days straight with their
kids and the kids love it and the adults
love it and everyone becomes so much
closer but the crazy thing is these
children they get to think like
visionaries to get to think in a whole
different way that school cannot yet
give them yeah I love that idea of
integrating the intergenerational wisdom
exactly it's called transgenerational
learning transgenerational learning
right
yeah and then you also have the
individual curriculum for 6 to 12 year
olds but then you have them show up at
the actual transgenerational learning as
well and that that then they're running
around and getting inspired like encore
did with Naveen that that definitely
does open up one's mind especially as a
parent or as a student to the
possibilities outside of the educational
curriculum what can I do
my kid that is different a different
path that can enrich them to become
wildly more successful in the world yeah
that's good okay you also chose Tallinn
in Estonia right and you did so for a
very specific reason so tell us about
that reason well I I the last mine Bell
University campus was in Tallinn Estonia
that spelled T ALL I and n now Estonia
is an incredible country
I consider Estonia an example of where
the world is going to be in the future
firstly it has the highest number of
startups per capita secondly the people
are incredibly healthy I believe it has
the second highest number of Olympians
per capita it really easy to incorporate
a business which makes it easier than
right being and it's really freaking
like like innovative when it comes to
tech lots of billion-dollar companies
like Skype like transfer why wise emerge
from Estonia and the cool thing about
Estonia is its tech is everywhere but
tech is invisible so when you go to a
stone you find that the country is 51%
forested people are very attuned with
nature sports that relate to nature are
really popular over there there's a huge
music and art scene it's just stunningly
beautiful I love being there the weather
is [ __ ] because it's it's close to
Finland for freezing cold temperatures
yeah well but but you get used to it but
I wanted to introduce Estonia to the
world because I love where the country
is going but also because I'm an
Estonian resident my children were born
in Estonia my wife is Estonian yeah yeah
in Europe go to Europe and go to North
Europe you point you want to be I'm so
glad so glad you asked okay so yeah so
by the way feel watching this on my
facebook laven you're from Estonia go
ahead and just type a comment so
estonia's right here it's just south of
Finland right if you have a helicopter
you can fly to Finland in 18 minutes
from Tallinn to Helsinki in 18 minutes
and during the winter you can just drive
across the frozen sea just that's that's
amazing
if you're on it look slightly mad and if
you're mad cuz you at any point it can
just crack right but what's funny about
this globe is that it's
from pre-1991 because it's still the
USSR former Soviet Union so Estonia oh
no no it no this Union of Soviet
Socialist Republics so how you're right
the Baltics were part of the Soviet so
just looking yeah alright yeah one one
one one quick one quick thought about
this is is if you think about the
potential that a small country has to
make massive change fast the u.s.
becomes a 300 million person laggard in
terms of change China and India hahaha
one of a half billion people very
difficult to make change quickly to
everybody even though I disagree even
though China has a different type of a
governance system that enables them to
do so but Estonia's got what let me tell
it only has one point four million
people but let me tell you why that's
why I think that's [ __ ] firstly
China is making incredible change India
is India not so much India has
bureaucracy but the rate at which China
is changing is insane like like I mean
China China is is developing so fast and
they've got a billion plus people at
1.30 you know don't have a choice in
China that that's debatable here's why I
believe America isn't changing as much
so firstly one of the unique things
about Estonian history is that when the
Soviets
left right so the Soviets invaded
Estonia after World War two the and they
ruled it from like 1946 to 1991 and
communism was forced on Estonia so the
Communist Party was the official party
but when the Soviets left the Estonian
government had a simple law that said if
you served in the Communist Party sorry
you can no longer serve in government
all of a sudden a lot of folks who were
in their 50s 60s and 70s there were good
people but they served under communism
they were no longer eligible to be the
leaders so the first Estonian leader
Prime Minister president I forgot the
exact title was 35 years old the head of
banking was 30 years old so you have
people who were under 35 leading the
country
now when you put someone under 35 to
lead a country they're gonna think in
completely different ways so a stone
yeah this this president or this Prime
Minister who was under 35 I think one of
the things that he decided is that the
Parliament was gonna be completely
paperless they were gonna invest in
technology they were gonna embrace the
internet Wi-Fi was gonna be a human
right and it was gonna be accessible
everywhere and so you have a country
being led by young people and that's why
Estonia is is so good at change that's
why it's such an exciting place to be
that's why today Estonia has overtaken
Tel Aviv as the city with the world's
highest number of startups now you look
at America right you guys selected a 70
year old reality TV star to be your
president like what the hell were you
guys thinking do you really think he's
gonna be in tune enough to create change
I just read in the newspapers that he's
saying that America should go back to
coal and take down wind turbines cos
they kill birds well that means a 70
well person but if you don't know any
the progress you need to invest in your
youth so what I'd like to see is more
American leaders who are under 45 under
50 because like it or not they think
differently you look at if you don't
believe me just look at the startups
most startups are being created by
people under 40 so anyway it doesn't
matter whether they are left or right
that that Estonia has this obsession
with you America seems to believe that
you need to be 60 or 70 to be in
government and that's a [ __ ] idea
that holds America back from true
innovation if you're young
please freakin run for politics if you
are an American yeah we're starting to
see a lot of young people run for
political office right in getting very
inspirational a couple of years but then
assessing real women or gay or non-white
run for politics that diversity is so
important for a country you know
diversity of thought for sure right yeah
okay so there was a there's a lot to
unpack there I think that you're well
you you're spot-on about the youth I
think that the youth have been credit
ideas that need to get executed into the
world faster I think that's a really big
pillar of why yes don't even is
successful another aspect is just the
sheer 1.4 million people it's just way
easier to move than it is with hundreds
of millions of people or billion people
it's just way easier but I also am
totally feeling you on the youth a
couple questions that we like to ask on
the show I think that this one is
especially good for you as someone that
is found MindValley and is getting
transformative education to more people
let's ask you this what is your favorite
sort of transformative technology so
there many things I experiment with my
favorite transformative technology is
mine Valley quest because I've never
seen anything delivered those kind of
results but if you mean deeper in the
curriculum yeah it's got to be advanced
meditation particularly be the accessing
of altered states and and which even
further aspect of accessing an altered
state is it the future authoring is it
the those goal-setting is it the ability
to just relax and tune in or it and find
the intuitive that's that's kindergarten
meditation that's kinder there's a a lot
of a lot of meditation apps a lot of
stuff out there are basically teaching
you what I call kindergarten meditation
right it's about relaxing it's about
eliminating stress that's that's nice
it's important it's so so so so it's so
important but you can go deeper into
your practice and when you go deeper
into your practice I believe there are
two things that start to emerge the
first is that you can tap into an inner
voice to guide you so you can make more
effective decisions the second thing
that starts to happen is that you start
to feel more unity with the rest of the
world petty little ideas of nationality
or religion or whatever group you belong
to start to fade away and you feel more
collect more connected with the entire
world you've become a better human being
as Ken Wilber the philosopher might say
you move from ethnocentrism to world
centrism and cosmos centrism
now the third thing starts to happen and
that is where you start to feel almost
as if you're lucky you have ideas in
your head and you see that all of a
sudden like synchronicities coincidences
seem to happen and you seem to move more
effortlessly towards your goals so those
three things ten tips them to happen
when you go in deeper into a meditation
practice why do we have a timer there
that's our 15-minute timer so okay okay
the end of the session that was a really
good explanation of the quest and what
you unpack as you get deeper I like that
right there is something about the
dropping all of the walls of separation
between each other and the border is in
the color spective and everything right
I think is totally where we're going in
the long term but how we get there is
very intricately delicate because it's
still such a malleable world right and I
think that's a lot of the reason why we
still see some nationalist tendencies is
because we're entering into the
artificial intelligence biotechnology
all these crazy sort of exponential ages
and if we're not really careful all of a
sudden we could see some sort of a
massive earth that is controlled by only
one party malevolently and so that's one
of the reasons why I think we're staying
a little bit cautionary as we get to the
long term cosmic perspective goal okay
so that is one of the favorite
transformation technologies how about a
quick question on the way to the end on
the end couple questions is we right now
we're seeing a huge sort of shift in
terms of exponential technology
exacerbating wealth inequality it seems
as though that you know the pink
argument is true that the bottom is
slowly coming up at the top is just
exploding upward what do you see in
terms of how to sort of funnel resources
down the hierarchy and uplift people
well well I can tell you I don't think a
lot of people will like this answer but
I can tell you that a lot of the leading
minds I've encountered in Silicon Valley
have said that this is the way the world
is gonna be evolved so I was at a
conference recently and I saw Peter
Diamandis
Peter Diamandis of the XPrize and he was
quoting Elon Musk and he said that
universal basic income it's not a
question of if it's a question of whim
it's going to happen and then Peter went
on to say look a lot of Bill Gates said
then he was quoting Bill Gates and he
said Bill Gates said if robots are going
to take away our jobs tax the robots
what we are going to see is a
flourishing of human creativity is a
flourishing of human health is a
flourishing of being human because
robots are going to start taking away a
lot of the jobs that we don't want to do
and what's gonna happen is that taxes do
have to be levied on these companies
employing these robots and universal
basic income has already been it's
really being tested in places like camp
certain parts of Canada certain cities
in Finland and it's showing promising
results people do not become lazy when
their basic needs are taken care of
because they feel safer they actually do
a better job of raising their kids they
start becoming more productive they
start they start getting more educated
and I believe that's the future of the
world mark my words I will bet
everything I own on this within 50 years
universal basic income will be across
the United States no matter what
Republicans might say today yeah you you
make a really good point about I'm
better than you I thing I own I'm
betting everything I own 50 years from
now the universal basic income will be
everywhere across the United States
because the flourishing of humanity
that's a big bet yeah and like he said
repetitive work taken over by robotics
and artificial intelligence and
automation will enable many people to
become more creative more productive
better parents more time to do things
that they want to do for their health
for their actualization all this good
stuff and that's that's really important
and then the next question of course
with that is you know who pays for the
universal basic income is a tax on just
the robots will that actually be able to
pay for everything that's a whole
different conversation as well new on
well well actually a lot of economists
believe that this will be a healthy way
of running a country because look when
people's basic needs are taken care of
right when people when people's basic
needs are taken care of they actually
get to be more productive without
worrying
about things and so in that now so
there's a whole bunch of economic forces
which are going to come into play but
the other trend which is going to help
us get there is that wealth the
accumulation of wealth will take on a
different meaning well really seeing
this with the beginning pledge that Bill
Gates created people become billionaires
and then they give away their wealth
that's also gonna start happening I mean
you can't take it with you when you die
and so you're increasingly gonna find
that this generation this emerging
generation including people like Larry
Page and Mark Zuckerberg they are they
are hard-wired to be philanthropist oh
yeah conspicuous consumption doesn't get
you anything giving you to make the
world a better place makes you fulfill
thank you exactly
okay I still you know we'll have to
unpack at a later time how we actually
end up writing for things like universal
basic income and stuff like that okay
so a couple last questions this one is
someone excited here perspective on do
you think we're alone in the cosmos of
course not like what why would anybody
even suggest such a dumb idea the reason
is because as recently as February last
year I remember that I remember reading
alright now I may have the numbers wrong
but scientists discovered that there are
ten times as many stars in the known
universe as what they previously thought
and it is insanely ridiculous to think
that we are the only sentient beings on
a on a rock hurtling through space and
then a follow-up question to that is do
you think that were in a simulation I
think that there is a so I was attending
I was attending a private XPrize event
on virtual reality and augmented reality
and on stage they put six of the leading
thinkers in this city working on a are
VR and AI right including people like
including people I know friends of mine
who are working on some really
cutting-edge companies now when that
question was asked by about a six
said yes they believe we are living in a
simulation and they were pressed why do
you believe that they said well what we
are seeing in terms of how resolution
right and quality of these VR
experiences are getting better and
better and AI is getting better and
better we can see the intersection of
these two and we know that this life
that we see will be there's a very good
chance that within a hundred to two
hundred years we'll be able to
manufacture this now the other reason is
not just our progress in in in VR and
artificial intelligence in that
intersection but think about it right
the human species
who we are today human beings we've only
been around for relatively short amount
of time the earth is what four point
four point three billion years old right
and human beings have been around for
around five hundred five hundred
thousand to two million that that's a
tiny slice and look at how fast we are
progressing with with exponential
technologies it's very well likely that
there are civilizations out there in
space who have existed as much as a
billion years longer than us now where
do you think we will be in a billion
years and it's mind-boggling but very
likely a billion years from now we will
be able to create a universe yeah maybe
even much faster than that right my one
of my favorite parts is being able to
tweak the variables in this Emile
exactly and B was able to observe how it
evolves and also just be able to jump
into differently designed simulations at
my leisure super fun I'm glad that you
have a very Pro simulation esque aspect
to it and you also you know a lot of
people we feature just have a binary
answer but a lot of people we feature
also have a very nuanced and in-depth
answer and that's always really fun so
I'm glad that's good all right last
question mm-hm what do you think's the
most beautiful thing in the world the
most beautiful thing in the world who so
I can't tell you but well I guess I can
it was other than all the usual stuff
right because everyone is gonna say it
was it was the birth of my baby daughter
if that was of course absolutely
beautiful but other than all the usual
stuff if I have to think about some of
the most beautiful human experiences
there was one that stands out and it was
Burning Man 2014 watching the man burn
while being high on certain substances
figured oh yeah and that that was that
was amazing now tell us why was the man
burning so profound well you know I
can't sum it up and I can't you can't
sum up something like that in words
better but I take burning - a really
cool experience awesome this has been
super enriching mission this is such a
pleasure to be able to feature you and
talk about my valley to be able to talk
about all the different quests that
anyone can sign up for and get
themselves more educated about intuition
meditation about entrepreneurship and
also go to the actual campuses that
you're popping up around the world and
having these communities grow and
flourish and become a student in the
process transformation transformation
the first transformative school I love
it thank you
this has been such a pleasure thanks for
coming on to the show we greatly
appreciate it
everyone if you guys had a good time let
us know about it in the comments below
tell us what your thoughts are we'll
have a nice link for you in the bio to
get signed up with MindValley also
subscribe join the family join the team
join us on patreon and help us supports
help us sustain this endeavor grow it
across the world increase the impact and
thank you very much to Ron a producer
and director thanks mark who's also in
town an assistant production we have a
lot of awesome stuff coming up for you
the next couple of days so definitely
get pumped for Jace's Silva on Thursday
we have an exclusive end with the
battery coming up on Friday featuring
Aubrey de Grey and we have
an epic live event coming up with new
meme Jane on Monday so get jacked for
all of that much love everyone thanks
for tuning in mission MindValley thank
you very much something for having us
awesome thanks everyone peace
[Applause]
[Music]